hey guys this is dennis the founder of
think here i'm david griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of almost human
episode nine unbound so this is this is
like the terminator-esque episode with
the gina carano
social artist basically yeah basically
being the terminator one i actually like
this episode i i think it was one of my
favorites so far and i think one of the
main reasons is
that they established
a villain character
that didn't get caught at the end of the
episode
that
you know wrapped up out nice and neat it
seems like they've built the jo what's
his name john laraquette from nightcore
yeah he's changed from nightcore he
plays this doctor with vaughan yeah who
created like dorian like that has the uh
created the the artificial intelligence
soul yeah robot soul
synthetic synthetic soul yeah so i liked
all the scenes with him and it kind of
gave me that that uh fringe kind of
feeling yeah yeah where they actually
were talking about actual science
fiction and ethics and all that stuff
and i was like wow this is actually
deeper than more than the other episodes
have been yeah it was it was solid you
know good action you know i see junior
carano you know get a little work you
know after you know fast and furious
movie um
i liked it did the ending kind of
through when we started throwing in some
method like some not mythology but some
more
story like this whole wall like did they
mention the wall yeah if they did it was
in passing right it's like the wall and
he wouldn't go to the wall what are you
like what's his wall thing i mean at
least at least on this episode because i
have been asking for it so i have to
give it credit uh we got a little more
of the in syndicate you know they talked
a little bit about it they you know i'm
assuming maybe this guy's working for
them or working with them so the you
know this kind of
mad scientist guys so i mean at least we
got more of that it was nice seeing
dorian get to meet his maker i liked the
ending when you know uh john was talking
about how i mean can you imagine if you
met your maker and then he betrayed you
you know so yeah
we saw the betrayal coming i mean well
it was obvious yeah
the whole episode right but i was just
glad that okay let's turn this guy into
especially because i think john larcen
did a really good job
as this uh dr vaughn character right he
i mean he seemed like he was distraught
over what had happened but then
obviously he admitted to like anger
right like i like that part where he
talks about when he built a
the xr xnr or whatever the advanced one
that gina corona is that it came from a
place of of anger and frustration yeah
because i mean they shut down they took
away his work his life's work and i
think it seems like he's driven by that
now i mean even when they pulled him up
on that wall he looked kind of scared
going up there so i'm assuming it's a
place he
hasn't been cause i imagine if it was
like his second third or fourth time you
know going up there and shooting up he
would be fine but he looked really
nervous so he's
you know
he's pursuing something but maybe he's
not you know he's not sure what he's
getting himself into yeah it was
probably some sort of deal he he made
through intermediaries and right you
know maybe electronic communication but
i don't think it's something he's like
you know he's not going over there being
the leader or something no no i mean who
knows who this they probably promised
him like oh we'll give you a lab you
build this army for us right of like
synthetics and then you know we'll take
back the city or something like that and
you you can get your place restored yeah
and i just hope you know looking ahead i
hope next week they build off that and
don't just give us something see that's
what i'm afraid of i know it's going to
give us other languages i saw the
preview and it did not
look like it had that and said i think
that's the biggest weakness of the show
is here's a good episode
like you were right build off of it
because i wanna know more about the wall
one about more in syndicate i wanna know
about the like what's the wall there for
why is the wall that's interesting i
wanna know is there is it like a is this
judge dread is there a wasteland the
radiated wasteland i mean what's going
on beyond the wall i don't know
yeah so yeah in general i thought i
thought it was the strongest episode so
far and i would have i would like them
to continue on this path but it doesn't
look that way it was a good episode it
does not beat the sex bots that is still
my favorite episode episode two david in
the sex box he loves this i love sex
boss you gotta have sex bots so i mean
uh but this episode was good i like
seeing junior carano it was a strong
episode and i hope
if it is like another crime of the week
that's fine but i hope at the end maybe
they build off of what we learned this
week we'll see all right all right guys
so uh that's what we thought of almost
human you can post your comments below
on the website or on our youtube channel
think hero pro make sure to subscribe to
that uh you also come check us out on
twitter i've talked to dennis michael
and myself about almost human rather you
know exciting new shows you're watching
uh we're at think hero i'm at griffinde
and we also have a facebook page that's
facebook.com think hero fans and make
sure you like that page and share our
videos on twitter facebook and other
social media
you